hey david so it turns out hunter biden
is now being investigated so now what
will this be a cloud over joe biden for
his entire presidency i believe the
answer is no
here's why i don't believe so to to back
up the story
back in um
the pre-election part of 2020
this outrageous conspiracy um was put
together
which alleged this is like a blend of
all the different things
uh hunter biden joe biden's son
needed to get some laptops with really
sketchy stuff on them repaired so he
flew across the country from the west
coast to the east coast and brought
these three laptops while drunk directly
to a particular repair shop
at which the person doing the repairs
and taking the laptops in was legally
blind and it's unclear how well he was
even able to see who was dropping off
the laptops
and then
hunter biden after flying across the
country to get these important laptops
fixed
left them there and never picked them up
and what the repair guy did
was instead of i guess just trying to
get the laptops back to their owner he
went in and read hunter biden's private
emails
on the laptop
and
was convinced that it was hunter biden
because one of the laptops has a bo
biden foundation sticker on it this is
the so-called laptop from hell as it's
been dubbed by donald trump
then
the repairman found what was on there so
sketchy that he gave it initially i
believe it was to the fbi and when the
fbi didn't do what the repairman wanted
done with the laptop
after months the repair guy called rudy
giuliani
and gave him the hard drive or laptop
and the rest is history okay so that's
that's the story
what is going on right now with hunter
biden has nothing to do with that now
what what hunter biden is in the middle
of is an investigation related
to reportedly i believe it's 110 or so
thousand dollars in unpaid taxes hunter
biden says he's cooperating fully with
the investigation
he believes he paid all the taxes he
should have and he's cooperating period
so this has nothing to do with a laptop
from hell first and foremost that's an
important thing to remember
and uh i don't think that i mean listen
republicans have given the option
they'll do investigations they'll call
for a special counsel whatever but uh
hunter biden certainly
um is not going to be part of joe
biden's administration i know that we
may now because of donald trump think
well obviously hunter biden's about to
be a high high-level advisor to joe
biden no
no that that's
uh that that's not going to be the case
and um as a result i i think that this
is not going to generate
um the sort of titillation that many on
the right are hoping now i would find it
fascinating if joe biden came out and
said
no one is above the law
people should get their day in court
and everybody should be subject to
investigation if law enforcement
believes there's been wrongdoing even if
it's the child of a president of the
united states
and step completely out of the hunter
biden thing which is going to be
resolved in due course
and of course the implication of joe
biden saying that would be this also
applies to don jr and to eric trump and
to ivanka and to jared kushner and
whoever else
the conspiracy theories about hunter
biden will explode but i would be
shocked if this became what some in the
conspiracy right are sort of hoping that
it will become i may be wrong and we
will see
when you see me sitting here at the
microphone oftentimes i'm wearing a
shirt by a company called teddy
stratford and i love these shirts so
much that i asked teddy stratford to be
a sponsor of the show and here's why i
like their shirt so much with other slim
fit button-up shirts you often get this
weird-looking gap between the buttons
where it looks kind of stretched out but
teddy stratford actually has a patented
zipper that's hidden underneath the
buttons which secures the shirt against
your chest so it doesn't look stretched
and most importantly it just provides a
nicer looking fit overall and the entire
shirt is specially designed to really
improve the way your upper body looks
when you're wearing it it also has a
special type of collar that prevents it
from drooping down and spreading open
which is another
really great thing about these shirts
all of these things really do a lot to
make a big difference when you're
looking at a shirt and that's why i like
to wear teddy stratford shirts on the
show go check them out at
davidpakman.com
teddy the link is down below and they'll
give you 15 off your first order if you
use the coupon code pacman at checkout